you
hi everyone is Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a five
oh game let's try Knight f6 and maybe go
for some nimzo-indian defense we have
that no increment okay let's start with
b6
and swing the back completely around
nothing fancy I could consider dropping
back on e7 in reply to a three because I
have enough control reform
you
now let's castle prepare to give up my
bishop for the night if questioned hmm
let's strike we could with a d5
in the center so on a three I'm going to
drop back now I've control over the e4
break and I'll be looking for c5 soon
it's a bit more appealing to do it now
or maybe after a capture mm-hmm might
want to lure the bishop away and
actually then damage the structure maybe
I could go for this Bishop takes Knight
yeah I'm going to try for this and
strike it this guy I'd really like to
have C takes D eat takes D and satellite
with these double isolated pawns Bishop
our pond I don't want to allow white to
get some time with b4 so I know I'm
giving myself this isolated pawn but I
don't want to help this kind of
development and where does my knight
belong c6 or d7 let's go here say
Foursquare defended and maybe just pivot
here right away
I think I like this idea expecting
Bishop e2 but at least I can drift over
at these these squares do nothing about
this pawn I could take with check now
kingi to night h4 hmm where the king
really go after that night on h4 check
King g29 h4 King g3 or h3 um I'm going
to try for it at least we'll make for
something exciting if the King goes
crazy
consider Knight d5 give the pawn back
and at least my bishops defending the
knight okay they didn't move forward so
where to go with the Queen how about hmm
let's go here maybe Knight f3 into h2
might actually isn't that a matin -
threat close close to it
Knight f3 Queen h2 I'm up upon let's
just complete development here he's a
loose piece but I could always drop back
to f5 or g6 this may be a bit sensitive
point g7 Queen set
I don't necessarily have to move that
night mmm I'm going to though I didn't
like moving my night to have my bishop
defend here just going to tuck him in
I'm up upon I have the safer king and
now this diagonal is weakened
how about we just trade why not okay
they don't want further trades all right
that's an open file 221
I Knight g4 and E for both appealing my
knight can revisit this square let's
start with a check see what see what
white does and maybe even night here
hmm let's do this first I'm fearful if I
play 94 I end up in self pin Knight g4
with tempo and then I could stay on that
square let's go further
Knight h5 into g3 maybe Queen h1 may
clean trade hmm
feel like I should be keeping Queens on
let's keep the clean zone
safer King it's very tempting for me to
want to just trade there okay I have a
clean g3 move oh boy I have to be a bit
careful here
hmm that Bishop is really strong
I'm in a 30 okay we're going to take I
think I might go in for a night here oh
my goodness they could play that
straight away I totally missed it
ah man not cool
mmm oh wow what a blind spot whoops
okay yeah that's nope that's not cool
though I was thinking rook takes and
then I would address the threat there oh
man
and then it's just this kind of pain
follow-up mmm
no good no good no good I guess I have
to do this
Wow threatening the Queen it's about it
and now everything is collapsing and
okay laying down a piece probably get
away taking here okay hmm
that's stuff that is very tough got
nothing
21
as well ah that's really painful to just
miss that simple tactic all right let's
just see why finish me off here many
ways to do it yeah that's probably one
of them I guess we'll go here my king
will be running for the hills
soon clean checking here rook takes pawn
okay yeah that'll do it as well I got
some kind of mate coming up or that one
time to resign mmm missed a simple
tactic there I saw it
I saw the bishop pinning the pond but I
was just a blind spot taking nf5 hmm
well aside from that I guess I the big
thing here to question is was it the
right idea to exchange Queens or not I
think the reasoning I used with you
wanting to keep the Queens on the board
is correct
just having the safer king but hmm maybe
I could have just played it being up
upon and the Queen's off and not been
too focused on trying to get up the king
mmm another take on this position let me
just flip the board for a moment another
take on this position right here let's
see right around here when there's the
offer of a queen exchange maybe I mean
this is this is kind of giving light a
free move you know it's a strictly
defensive move here that I'm playing
Queen c7 and I give why I'm giving no
direction to white whatsoever you know
the they could do whatever they want to
try to improve an example would even be
Knight here just improving the night and
unmasking the bishop and they have these
two bishops pointing at my king
maybe it's actually my king in a way
who's a bit more vulnerable even though
the white pawns are further away from
the king and I'm beginning to think that
the my assessment of me having the safer
King is not correct
hmm and I guess I miss evaluated this
is the queen will be a fine enough
defender it's a different story if I'm
able to get this dis move in but no I
guess I could I guess I should have
traded Queens like I think my decision
was okay and we'll reveal with the
computer but I think my decision is all
right with going in for this capture and
also deciding to capture here and play
with an isolated pawn just to sidestep
this type of speedy development and then
just kind of drift over towards the the
squares over here where white is
weakened well we'll see what the
computer is saying especially I'll be
I'll I'll be a bit curious to see what
it says right here if it really wants to
hunt down my night because well King
here I could give a check first so if
there is some way to attack the night
king age three and then I believe I was
going to do something like this to give
the pawn back and then you know
something like this my knight at least
is defended with the bishop even
material but pretty exposed King can
they really get at him I'm not sure but
uh yeah kind of rolling the dice um it's
not really a position you can for me at
least one that I could calculate
completely out I mean look at the tactic
that I missed it's just a one move shop
but uh getting getting back to this this
moment here where there is once again
the option to trade Queens it'd be a
different story if I avoided the Queen
exchange and let's say through some
punch but I'm not doing that
so White has their pick to do whatever
it is they want and yeah f5 and I may
already be in trouble actually with this
move because the alternative to play
here there's this capture I could take
here but
there's at least an in-betweener to get
the pawn back not sure who stands better
here hmm tough call I think any of us
have a good pun in the position
also on the Queen trade there isn't the
win of material I saw this with the
follow-up check there is a block
and still tricky to assess here one two
three I am down upon but they'd have the
bishop pair and I have some a couple
weak bonds over here I don't know it's
tough to assess this one this ending if
I went for it I was looking for
something more but there really wasn't
something more for me I don't think I'm
not I'm not so sure I had the safer King
with the Queen here the bishop here both
bishops pointing at my king I think it's
simply the wrong assessment that I made
in game but let's have a look at it with
computer and see where we can improve
maybe even in the opening as well okay
stockfish let's see a quick point or two
from this one
nothing nothing great happening in the
opening no great shifts this is an idea
to take doesn't want to give up the
bishop pair but it's it's an option
that's what I was going for the damage
or the structure that's the bit of a bit
of a trade-off okay it wants to go with
V takes my positional sense says to go
like this to maintain these two guys but
this is what concerned me be for in
Bishop to b2 I don't want to help that
dark square Bishop out so I was willing
other words to damage my structure so
that light couldn't gain that time b3
just trying to drift over towards the
Kings side it recommends f4 now and now
Bishop to b2 what would I do on f4 Queen
c7 Bishop b2 rook a to b8 hmm I'm not
quite sure what the point of that is I
really don't see what kind of influence
the rook is going to have on the B file
especially with this bishop on c4 okay D
one let me just play out
few more moves kind of get a feel clean
see six trying to sneak in here cleany
to Knight b6 okay then okay I can start
to see it now this this is at least the
idea it starts to make a bit more sense
to me when I see Roque to be a combined
with Knight b6 because this tries to
rattle the bishops position on c4 Bishop
b5 Queenie hey it's a funny move staying
on this diagonal cutting right into
these squares keep in close eye on one
of the two holes f3 there's multiple
holes these 3 H 3 F 3 and H 4
okay just want to get a little bit of a
feel behind this rookie to be eight idea
they didn't prevent Knight to e5 in the
game so I hopped right in and I could
get away with taking so they shouldn't
allow that I was expecting Bishop e2
they didn't go for it but I could get
away with this King g2 night h4 is fine
and the King goes back so let's just
investigate this king h3 ooh
queen c8
interesting in on King takes night
it's a maintance seven starting with E
five ah that's nice it's writing queen
g4 and they have to do stuff like Rick
d7 oh man
all the other thread is just to move the
night here huh followed up with g6 stuff
luring the king closer as an example if
the Queen comes here to cover g5 now
it's even faster
there's Knight h5 Queen King takes h5
Queen h3 oh that's nice I figured
there's there's something something
there the King is moving forward I don't
know that I would have spotted Queen to
c8 though in this position I was
thinking more along the lines of after
King h3 to give the pawn back with this
and it's holding as equal but yeah you
can't really go by that assessment it's
really it could go any way and it's too
tough to assess such a open position
King on h3 Queen still on board to
Knight still on board but Queen c8 don't
I don't see myself playing this but it
is best there and then running into mate
and 75 rook d7 Bishop e6 I guess these
threats are just too strong too
move the night to threat and queen g4 to
threaten queen g4 right here and also
just a night move to h5 and then queen
h3 I'm making one idea and also I'm
makin one to idea that's pretty neat
I like that okay well he went back he
sensed the danger and then Queen c7 is
fine just occupying an open file we
exchanged and I ran away first okay
exchange rooks is fine 98 on 94 as well
I played h5 at one point hmm I guess I
could be a bit more direct 94 Queen g2
and then Knight to d6 hmm I didn't
really consider that kind of maneuver no
I mean I'd be looking more along the
lines of if I'm going to play 94 I want
to next support him if he's attacked
with f5 well I can't do that how many
times I'm going to miss this Bishop huh
my idea when I did play h5 and I don't
know how clear I was during the game
with explaining why I went for h5 here
but I wanted to be able to play Knight
g4 and after and not have to react to
the Queen applying pressure by night I
wanted to get there and have some
stability for that night for at least
one move and then try to work in another
piece as an example if white isn't
playing h3 let's just say a passing move
then there's Knight g4 the Queen could
come over here to attack the knight and
okay I'm entering here and I'm not
saying the Queen g3 is the best move but
I just you know wanted to point out I
have some stability here yeah I have
pressure on e3 you know and well there's
there's winds all over the place taking
on the pot taking the pawn going to d2
at this stage because there's no rip
block but they took away that idea with
h3 close to a pawn advantage for me so
h4 what's better than that night h4 what
night h4 right away and on Queen takes
Knight route D - um yeah
kind of tough to spot rook here 94 okay
yeah I'm not going to see that not in a
blitz game at least that's pretty wild
night h4 move I went with something a
bit more positional minded h4 and I'm a
couple steps away from that and now it's
pretty even I mean I am up that pond but
Queen g2 is a good move and I'm
expecting after I play Queen c7 that is
close to lost f5 is just a strong move
f-five is top move too strong of a
opinion but saying it's lost
but f5 is good and it's holding as even
there is we could say compensation
clearly for white I have that material
plus but it's not really feeling like I
have a material plus here 95 takes takes
and we arrive at that position I was
pointing out first this move yeah holds
is even but it's anyone's guess who is
really the better side here it's a tough
one for me to evaluate and well whites
I'm on move here suggesting Queen g3
maybe a way to go I didn't really see it
as I think I went as far as thinking
well if I play 95 they're going to win
the pawn back but maybe I could have
also looked at it in a different way
where I say to myself well on the other
hand White has the bishop pair so yes
I'll give up on back but at least I'll
take out the bishop pair and play this
position where it's finally for at least
this one moment a bit calm there's no
punch being thrown my way and I have
kind of like a free play I could try to
come up with something it's suggesting
Queen g3 from here but it'd be a tough
one from here for sure and it much more
quickly of course I take and it's just
lost to this simple tactic
oh well it's going to happen happen here
you saw it firsthand
and there was no opportunity for me here
running into main 6 3 2 and matin 1 if I
played out one more maybe five would
have been mate but at this point I
resigned okay
tough loss as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye